Tại vì tưởng tượng tương thì trong thời gian thối ra hài giờ thì hệ thống của nhà mạng.
Phát hiện một thứ bao của hạt động hai độ tý vị đều quý,
sau với số đăng ký trước đó, rất nghe bệnh thông phải tiến hành gà suác
phát hiện và tạm dừng dừng dừng bụng chầu đi lụ thế bảo như hoặc hiện thành nhận tý.
Trong thế gian này nhà mạng đồng thời gưới thống vào yêu cầu chủ thế bảo
thì hiện sắc thực sinh chắc học quân mạng.
Gibt này sẽ được thực hiện của hai các vùng qua dịch bụng sắc tật địa từ hộng đối chơi trước tiếp.
Trong đó, việc sắc thực qua dịch bụng lịch từ về bảo đảng Trung Quốc
với yếu lợt trong cơ sở dưới lợt cuộc già, vừa ra đường cờ,
cơ sở dưới lợt hành cơ, cơ sở dưới lợt cuộc già, bể xuất nè kai.
Dưới lợt được lưu tại bộ phận lưu chí thống tým tình được mạng hóa của thêm hành cơ.
Bởi các lưu chí ở chức tiếp thì nhà mạng sẽ só sánh hình này chúc chức tiếp khôn mạng của thuy bảo,
bảo đảng Trung Quốc với thông tý vị xin chắc học đã lưu chức hấp pháp,
tại cơ sở dưới lợt thông tým tý bảo của dưới lợt.
Trong chức hợp mời dùng không rất thật lạ trong bà mình ai kể tế khữ đổi máy.
Nhà mạng có thể tiên hành các biển pháp mạnh hật như khoá tý bảo hành cơ,
chấm rất đọc.
Sắc thực hơn mạng khi đổi tiếp bị là một trong những biển pháp tiếp theo nhóm ngắn chạm tình chạc,
sử dụng xí khẩu chiến chổ.
Theo chân ra, đi tệ này nhằm hạng chế tình chạm xím của mời dùng biển người khác lợt giống.